[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday april the 29th
i'm fraser nelson standing in for andrew
neal
on this week's show we're going to be
covering the latest in the downing
street psycho drama who's going to come
out
on top boris dumb or perhaps carrie
our political editor james forsyth and
katie balls will give us
the latest then douglas murray and kate
andrews will discuss
whether britain really needs a first
lady then we'll turn on to the far
trickier question not who leaked the
second log down but whether
that lockdown was implemented on a false
premise
now we're going to be looking at the
covid in india question and then
ask if britain should be donating
vaccines as well as ventilators
and then finally looking at cyber
warfare we're going to be talking to sir
richard dearlove
the former head of mi6 about the new
tools head by russia and china and how
much we should worry
all that to come in the next hour but
before we get going we've got a new
app which you can get from the app store
or on android
it's got all of the spectator podcasts
the blogs the magazines
and for a special introductory offer
we're offering three months
absolutely free full digital access
the offer ends at midnight and sunday so
you can avail yourself of it by going to
spectator
dot co dot uk forward slash tv
offer and as ever a special thank you to
charles stanley one of the uk's leading
wealth
management firms and sponsor of
spectator tv without their sponsorship
we would have no show to show you that
one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange for spectator
is the oldest magazine in the world
we're delighted to be partners with
charles stanley
okay to business this week's psycho
drama is depicted
in the front cover of this week's
magazine we had a pretty
tricky job how do you sum up everything
in all of its elements well
you can see what we've done here we've
got boris in bed not wanting to wake up
because of the nightmares
surrounding him dominic cummings
nicholas sturgeon on one side
a cop 26 bunny at the end of the bed a
dyson fan
but when he opens his eyes he sees
carrie simmons his fiancee with a very
long bill
a bill whose um financing is now the
subject of an electoral commission
inquiry james forsyth who writes our
cover piece this week
says that of all the allegations facing
boris right now and there are quite a
few of them
the wallpaper gate as it's becoming
known is the most potent
he joins me now along with katie balls
james
is this really the most serious charge
leveled to boris johnson after the year
that britain's just had
the question about the darling street
flat and its redecoration is different
because
this involves money and therefore there
are documents and a trail of
of what happened and and the electoral
commission have now launched an
investigation into it
and that is going to reveal precisely
how it was funded
and i think for that reason it's easy of
a separate
order to to uh the other claims
against him right um katie can you tell
us
what they're thinking in number 10 of
this i mean on one level you could say
look
all the things that have gotten wrong in
britain in the last year the question of
who paid for
the um the wallpaper or number 10 is
pretty low down voters priorities
even though it might set the westminster
village of flutter
yeah i think the official line or the
line that you hear the most if
you ask this question figures in number
10 is that no one cares about this
this is a bubble story and it shows yet
again how perhaps the lobby
and perhaps opposition depending which
anger you're going on are
tripping them ourselves up and something
which isn't really of that much
interest to the average person on the
street however
i think that let you scratch the surface
a little bit more i do not think there
are particular nerves this is going to
change how the party performs in the
local elections they're not picking that
up from campaigners from ministers who
are going out there from the party
chairman
but it is very clear to everyone in
government that the prime minister is
incredibly rattled
by the recent stories particularly the
flat refurbishment
but also other stories regarding his
text messages that have been made public
and it's really getting to him at prime
minister's questions this week boris
johnson seemed very angry indeed
um even though kyocera didn't manage to
land i suppose
fatal blows in that exchange by the end
the prime ministers just appeared to be
shouting about various things that
weren't particularly connected
and i think it is having an impact
because we're constantly told i will
know the government's focused on
at the pandemic the government is
focused on the vaccine ruler it's not
focused on this but
the actions and the behavior the prime
minister suggests that despite all that
talk
his mind is on this route but james this
is about far more than wallpaper we all
know that
it's about honesty it's about integrity
it's about transparency
and surely the danger facing boris
johnson is there are a great many people
in parliament and certainly outside it
who thinks he isn't particularly honest
or
transparent and that he simply has been
rumbled and is displaying
a fundamental character flaw that makes
him unfit for office so this
might be the threat which if you pull it
might unrevel his whole um premiership
so i think the question here is i mean
everyone knew that boris johnson is a
bit chaotic a bit
disorganized and i think if that comes
out in the inquiry and that it's a late
registration or this or that
but then i think then i think he will be
able but i mean that is kind of priced
in with voters
but if it comes out and it looks venal i
think that would be
very different and would draw a very
different reaction from people
i think his defense will be look you
know there's no taxpayer
money involved beyond the 30 000 pounds
that all prime ministers are offered
each year for the upkeep of the flat
but but i think if if it comes out uh
and and the whole paper trail looks very
awkward
and embarrassing then i think that that
could be difficult i think that i think
this is
a fascinating moment because as casey
said we've got a big set of elections
coming up next week
and the tories are optimistic about how
they will do there's there's even taught
that they might
win the hartley ball by election which
would suggest that you know that there
is still
but that kierstad hasn't managed to stop
the bleeding in the in the red wall for
labor
but there is no doubt that the biggest
threat to this political realignment in
england at the moment
is the fact that it's too principal
architects boris johnson and dominic
cummings
have fallen out in this spectacular
fashion
and they are now in what seems quite
close to all-out war and boris johnson
as the elected politician is the one
with far more to lose
katie what will happen next in this
all-out war do we imagine that dominic
cummings is sitting there with a lot
more
ammunition a lot more quotes that boris
johnson might have issued behind closed
doors
in moments of anger because certainly
the one we had this week the let bodies
pile high rather than implement
a third lockdown that certainly seems to
have got quite
wide resonance and that's sort of thing
that voters might not forgive them for
wallpaper perhaps who cares but
certainly in the attitude of that he was
prepared
to tolerate higher casualties because
out of some ideological aversion to
lockdowns
that is a far more potent accusation
than one people might well
remember yes and i think that when we
look at why
we're currently in this psycho drama or
the latest round of it
is because boris johnson made the
decision to brief to the papers that he
blamed dominic cummings for a series of
leaks and it was that drip drip effect
of
it's not just a flat it's not just one
comment it's not just one set of
messages between him and a world leader
or
you know an entrepreneur on ventilators
is the fact that you never quite know
when it's coming i think has really worn
the prime minister down
and if you speak to uh allies of dominic
cummings a they will say well
how do you know every leak is dominic
cummings how do you know any leakers so
there is not an acceptance that it is
but there's also a sense that there is
plenty more where that came from
dominic cummings was ultimately uh at
the top of this government some would
say running it depending uh
who you speak to for some time and
they've had access to everything
given this row is getting more toxic by
the day i think you could feasibly see
more negative stories i also think the
fact that at the moment dominic cummings
is blamed for every story particularly
in certain papers
gives others cover to come out with
stories but i think the date that should
really worry the prime minister
and does is the 26th of may which is
when we are currently expecting
dominic cummings to appear before the
coveted inquiry by the science and
health committees
into the government's pandemic response
and this is one where dominic cummings
in the past has not shown that he
particularly loves parliamentary
inquiries
he was once found to be in contempt of
parliament uh for skipping one on fake
news
when he did appear in one during the eu
referendum he started the session by
saying
i'm just fyi i've got a meeting at four
so i can't stay later than that which
landed very badly but this time around
in his blog he's saying
i'll take all the time in the world
answer any questions you want i'll show
you any messages in relation to it
i don't think that's because dominic
cummings suddenly loves you know commons
inquiries
i think that's because he has a lot he
wants to say and the problem for boris
johnson is yes we have anonymous
briefings
but it's not too long before cummings
wants to actually go on the record
so james in your cover story this week
you talk about
meeting andy street who's running
re-election as west midlands mary you
spent some time with him
your impression is that electorally
things are going
reasonably well for the tories of the
north of england and if they can prove
that the tory effect has outlasted
brexit has outlasted jeremy corbyn
then boris johnson he might not quite
get out of jail free card but your
analysis
is that he will be able to say to his
party look yes
my personal life is chaotic yes i let my
fiance run up the mother of all bills
for redecoration
but i can still win elections and
therefore you should still bank me
boris johnson's relationship with his
parliamentary party is transactional
um lots of tory mps had doubts about him
in 2019
but they still voted for him as leader
because they thought he was the only
person who could get the party out of a
hole
that it was in he's a winner he's a
campaigner and i mean the big question
after that 2019 general election when
the tories won that majority was
was this a one-off that tory electoral
coalition was kind of glued together by
get brexit done and fear of jeremy
corbyn
remove those two elements and and would
it all fall apart
and i think right now it doesn't look
like it is because one of the things
andy street said to me is you know
brexit just simply doesn't come up on
the doorstep at all now
yet you know the tories still think they
are in the good shot of holding the west
midlands penalty i think that suggests
that this realignment
is about more than just brexit i also
think that the vaccine
rollout is really uh helping the the
tories there's no doubt about that if
you look at the
uh approval of the government's handling
of coronavirus it's now up
up to 59 that's up from 30 last
september
um and you know 59 is where it was in in
in april last year when when we were
still in the first lockdown
so i i think the public's videos become
much more positive and i was very struck
and this i think has got to be the
tories great hope
for a set of election results that
enable boris johnson to try and change
the conversation is
you know i asked someone in the west
window and said yeah so who are you
voting for and they said well i've had
my jab as if that was an answer to my
question and i think i think boris
johnson's hope will be
a good set of election results will
enable him to
change the conversation now i i think we
should caveat that with the fact that
this electoral commission inquiry i
suspect will take time
and when it comes it could actually come
at a a
at a much more politically inconvenient
time for boris johnson
but i think the crucial thing to focus
on is is you know that boris johnson's
strength and weakness in a way
is just how relation transactional his
relationship with his parliamentary
party is
as long as the tories look like they are
winning then i think tory mps will be
prepared to stick with him
katie in your piece for the magazine
this week you look at the um
the sheer rate of churn in 10 downing
street how very few of those
who walked in there with by boris
johnson are still there
and in some ways the most senior
communications official
is his fiancee carrie simmons for a long
time he has tried to keep her
out of the news he hates it when she
gets mentioned
but right now not only is she on the the
cover of the spectator which is right at
the center of the story at the center
of the electoral commission's
investigation so do you think
from now on carrie simmons is going to
be
very much a figure in the story of the
boris johnson government
i think i think that is true i think
that she is becoming a figure of
increasing importance i think perhaps of
importance for some time but as you say
i think what's changed is it's much
harder now for downing street to say
this person is irrelevant uh they are
nor as they said they're a private
individual yes they are a private
individual but
the fact is they are an active player
and what is a scandal which is going to
run them for some weeks and months to
come
involving this flat now that means i
think we're going to keep seeing that
person being written about and then i
think when it goes to number 10 staffing
we have had a situation where as you
touch on
it's not just dominic cummings other
votely people such as lee kane
we've also had james slack not a
factional figure who
was briefly director of communications
highly respected
uh you've had allegra stratton who was
supposed to be the prime minister's
spokesperson who
also has been moved to a different role
and i think that
these are just a handful but there's
more where that came from and it is
creating a sense of churn but also
we know this prime minister takes a long
time to trust people
and i suspect the events of the past
week or two perhaps the past few months
would not have helped his uh sense of
trusting easily
um and that means who in that building
will he actually listen to will he
confide in
the castle is getting smaller and
smaller and that means carrie simon's
of increasing importance katie and james
thanks
very much well the role of carrie
simmons is looked at by douglas murray
in his column for this week's
magazine he says that she's increasingly
becoming like an office for the first
lady
do we necessarily want to go down an
american route he joins me now
along with kate andrews or economics
editor who's got a bit more sympathy for
the idea
but douglas first of all i mean surely
we what we need is a recognition that
things have moved on that of course
um politicians spouses are going to be
important to them and carrie simmons is
always going to be influential
to boris johnson is it so bad to simply
acknowledge the facts
well i suggest in the beginning of my
piece that it's not a very good
arrangement in america
that having an office in the east wing
of the white house which is the office
of the first lady
isn't an entirely comfortable fit in the
us it makes american politics
less like democracy more like a court in
which
you don't only have the first lady or
perhaps at some point in the future the
first husband
but all the encumbrances of the first
children and much more
you have first ladies proposing
legislation you had this in the 1990s
with hillary clinton an exceptionally
uncomfortable moment
when the spouse of a president is
proposing legislation
for the country nobody elected her at
that point they did subsequently
uh nobody elected her at that point and
there's something extremely
uncomfortable about this that somebody
should
effectively get power simply by the fact
that
some decades earlier they were fortunate
enough or otherwise to marry somebody
who ended up becoming the president
right but not everybody can be a sort of
silent dennis thatcher i mean
you don't need to give carrie simmons
legislative
powers but surely a bit more formal
support would have
avoided this mess in the first place and
what we're surely seeing
is problems arising from a lack of
support
given to the office of the prime
minister's spouse or the lack of
well she she has had formal support she
has had a 100 000 pound a year
director of communications paid for
based in downing street to give her
advice as an extraordinary situation to
be in
i don't believe that dennis thatcher
ever benefited from any
such munificence in recent decades in
fact throughout history
the spouses of prime ministers in the
united kingdom have actually tried to
audition to show they do not
have influence dennis thatcher as you
referred to very successfully portrayed
himself as a sort of silly old buffoon
precisely to go under the radar in this
way sherry blair who is of course an
extremely distinguished and successful
barrister in her own right
was constantly having to demonstrate
during her husband's time in downing
street that she was not
mixing up her professional and her
personal life and i suggest
that is quite as it should be we do not
have first ladies or first gentlemen
we have not had first girlfriends before
and it is very desirable for our country
that that remains the case and kate
andrews perhaps
britain then is the model that america
should follow and not vice versa
well douglas is completely right to
point to the tension that the role has
created historically in the united
states
when george washington's wife martha
washington was first dubbed lady
washington
people felt very uncomfortable about
this it it rank of nobility and that was
exactly what america had just fought
to get itself rid of so the title itself
has actually been contentious uh really
going back
all the way in american history but i
would argue that perhaps it's the best
of a bunch of bad options because in
reality i think it's true certainly true
in america but
becoming increasingly true in the uk um
you have to have something to do
if you are in one of these positions we
no longer live in a society
where women are just automatically going
to do the domestic job
um and in america we have not yet had a
female president so it's always been a
woman who's been
in in this supportive role and i think
that's become more formalized
and possibly in a positive way and
douglas mentions
hillary care there and i think it's
almost the exception that proves the
rule
hillary care was a disaster it was a
seen as a huge
overreach of the first lady when bill
clinton appointed her
to be chair of that health reform task
force and it completely failed it never
properly got off the ground and i think
a large part in that was a feeling
that was not the role of an unelected
far less accountable person to be taking
on if the president wants to reform
health care that's one thing
but if their spouse wants to do it
that's quite another
the other initiatives that we've seen
from first ladies in recent years
are indeed fundamentally rooted in
politics
but they tend to be something that's
more on the sideline that feeds into the
president's agenda and at the end of the
day
the president of course is still
responsible and i think in 2021
um if you are a man or a woman in the
u.s or the uk
supporting the president or prime
minister there's a very real chance that
you've stepped away from your own career
we saw that with michelle obama
we saw that with hillary clinton and
here in the uk you know carrie simons
was
doing her own job she was came up
through the ranks of the conservative
party was working for bloomberg
she's somebody who's going to want to be
involved in some capacity
formalizing that i think is a much
better option than what we've seen over
the past few months
where because it is completely informal
it gets very very messy but also
you can't hold her or anybody else to
account in the same way you could
if all of this were formally on the
record
may i just ask though uh uh
kate if that's your contention how could
this situation be improved
how could the first girlfriend be more
accountable
if she had a larger office with a bigger
spend how would we hold her accountable
well the idea is that what she would be
doing wouldn't be behind the scenes
anymore
it would be public and everybody would
be able to say is this feeding into the
prime minister's agenda
does this feel right is this what the
prime minister was elected to do
and this sideline project has been given
to his fiancee
i think you would have more
accountability there but i think one of
the problems how
well it would be formalized what her job
was supposed to be
would be on the record and then if she
were doing things that
weren't in her remit in that position i
think would be much
more easily scrutinized and we'd be able
to call it out much faster i mean one of
the problems we've had
for months now is that when her name is
brought into this you have a lot of
people who say
she shouldn't be brought into this at
all that's sexist that's problematic
she has nothing to do with what happens
in downing street
and we should stop kidding ourselves of
course she has plenty to do
with what's happening in downing street
and in america
it's far from a perfect system i
completely agree with you douglas and it
may well cost some taxpayer money
but at least we're not pretending that
the situation isn't what it is
it's on the record it's formalized and
you can hold people accountable you can
scrutinize it at the moment
i almost think it's too easy to say
she's not involved
we should create a system in which we
can talk about her involvement
and you know be critical of it if
necessary
okay but can i can i ask a brass tax
question in this situation
and let's take an example i given the
piece uh uh 2020
uh uh there is a proposed badger call
because farmers and others in the uk
have a particular problem with badges
carrie simons apparently persuades
her boyfriend her fiancee the prime
minister that the cull
should be stopped and he does stop the
cull now that's against a lot of expert
advice and i'm
told that one of the communities that
suffered from this this
decision was the hedgehog community now
as it currently stands
uh there is no accountability uh for
carrie simons for this decision
but i do not see and i'm yet to be
persuaded that were there a formal
office of the first girlfriend in
downing street there would be any more
accountability
what would we do you can't chuck her out
you can't say to the prime minister i'm
sorry you've got to get a different
first girlfriend you've got to fire this
one
he may want to at some point but we
can't tell him to do that he's not in
our remit as voters
in the in the united kingdom if you want
political power
you've got to stand before the
electorate and offer yourself before the
electorate there is no other way
that is one of the principles of british
democracy it was one of the principles
that drove
our vote to leave the european union
accountability
of the elected to the electorate and the
proposition
that on top of the elected you get
spouses and in time
children and in america we currently
seem to have a sort of informal position
of the
the niece of the vice president i
suggest
if people want power in britain there's
only one way to get it and to wield it
which is to first put yourself before
the public
and see whether they like you or not
douglas i don't disagree with your broad
assessment but i think you're almost
asking a different question which is
whether or not the prime minister who is
the leader
with whom the buck ultimately stops is
being influenced
by the right people under the right
circumstances and that is really a
question
for him because he shouldn't allow
himself to be sueded especially
if the evidence isn't in favor of a
decision that he's making
but i think you can tackle that that and
also separately say
uh that in 2021 it might make sense to
formalize these processes more
uh so that people have something to do
more to do
when they're in downing street and often
have to give up what they were doing
before but also crucially so if they
step
out of that remit it's much easier for
the media
to come in and scrutinize that which i
think has actually been very very
difficult
possibly up until the past week over the
past few months
douglas murray and kate andrews thanks
very much indeed
now one thing the rao is so far missing
is um
what people have been talking about who
leaked the second lockdown but another
question has been enlivening the
scientific community was the second
lockdown
necessary in fact were any of the
lockdowns necessary to force
infections into reverse every single one
of these lockdowns was justified on the
grounds
that infections were rising quickly but
if you have a look at the data coming
out now it seems as if that wasn't the
case
after all i'm joined now by professor
simon wood
edinburgh university who recently
completed a study into this
and by professor tim spector from kings
whose zoe app
has been collecting all kinds of covered
information including
infection levels when they peaked and
when they started to go
down and professor woods can i start
with you
tell us a little bit about how you have
reconstructed the story of our recent
covid past and what you found when you
did so
okay so so what i did was to
look at the data on the number of deaths
daily
from covid and then simply tried to back
calculate to
when those people must have been
infected on the basis of the published
information
on the the distribution of time from
infection to death so how variable that
is and there are there are several
reasonable papers on that and and i try
to take into account the uncertainty
associated with it so you can do that
kind of
back casting if you like and work out
when when people
were infected who then sadly later died
um and if you did that
uh in the first wave or at the second or
third lockdown
what you tend to see is that it appears
that the cases were coming down
somewhat before the full lockdown was
called
um and indeed if you then try and
compute the the r number
um associated uh with that incidence
rate
that also appears to be below one before
lockdown
and the reason for looking at deaths um
is is because deaths really are
you know what they say they are that you
don't have this problem of
somehow working from an unrepresentative
sample
the deaths are pretty much a census of
what happened and
also with that that duration information
there's reasonably good information
available
and so those do seem to be two
reasonably good sources of information
with which to try and infer what was
going on right and tim spector your zoe
app has been
collecting m covid infections data in
real time
does that sound right to you what
professor wood has just outlined
well we started collecting data on about
the 24th
of march last year and so we weren't
really a position to mark the
exact timing of the first wave but on
the second wave you had quite a lot of
data by then the second wave we did
and there's no doubt that according to
our data
the uh it had already started we'd pass
the peak before
um lockdown so it was already going down
when the official lockdown came into
play
and on the the third lockdown
uh it it really coincided
depending on exactly where you you put
it but i think you
most of us looking at it thought the p
could already passed by the time of the
third lockdown so i think it would
support
um simon's view that based on the death
rates
you know looking at the the incidence
rates the new cases
uh the numbers uh were already past
their peak when when the official
lockdown came in
although of course people might have
reacted differently
uh on the build-up to those things so
the exact timing
isn't clear but certainly it does
raise a big question mark over this all
right now professor woods
and let's look at the second lockdown
that's the one at the focus of the
political
discussion right now and if your studies
show
that cases were not rising when the
second log down was introduced as
the politicians had thought at the time
that doesn't seem to make a lot of sense
what would have forced infections down
if not if not locked down
well i think there's there were a lot of
other things going on that
you know we had this tier system uh in
place um
that's one thing so there was active
management it's not as if it's all
you know complete lockdown or nothing at
all there was a lot in place but of
course
it's it's a slow process this it takes a
long time to turn the
the epidemic around and you kind of have
to wait for your measures to be
effective i think that's one aspect
i think the other aspect of course is
that people really do react to rising
deaths
um that you know you see the deaths
rising and suddenly you start thinking
again oh this is a serious a serious
business and i think people's behavior
is it probably changes in relation to
that but of course i can't prove that
that's what's happened
right you know there's a lot going on in
addition to the absolute full lockdown i
think and that's that's the
key thing all right and tim spector this
is a a hugely important issue of course
it relates to our understanding of
of the so-called non-pharmaceutical
interventions the npis
and what basically what drives down
covet whether
it is government policy or whether it's
people's
behavior i guess professor wood is
saying that when people read about
things getting worse in the news perhaps
they will then change their behavior
organically i don't know if you've got
you've got so many data points here
have you noticed any correlation between
and covered levels going up and down
or anything else happening if it's not
locked down what else could it be
well i think what we need to move away
from is that any sort of
black or white view of this that this is
either due to lockdown
due to vaccines uh due to
um you know people's fears
i i think it is many factors influencing
this and this is why
all uh epidemic
epidemiologists really have struggled to
model most other flu epidemics etc that
they do come and go and they do
in some extent have a life of their own
i think that's the other factor here
that
you know it's you know there's the
seasons there's the
the cold spells but there's also some
underlying wave
of the virus just coming and going in a
particular time when it
it reaches susceptible people so there
are many many factors here and i think
what we're fair we're really doing wrong
in this country is to is to
think it's an all or nothing thing about
lockdowns and
absolutely right the reason that the r
value
uh never keeps going down at the same
rate is people relax
because they don't see their neighbors
being driven to hospital
and the opposite occurs that when police
sirens are around
and you know their friends are dropping
down those people are going to stay
indoors and that's just normal you know
and
that's been going on for hundreds of
years that idea that when you're
surrounded by
danger so i think you know and
now at the moment of course we've got
vaccines uh coming into play
which half the population are under so
the idea that you can say it's all due
to this
or due to that is really uh
crazy and i think this is we've over
emphasized definitely the
the effects of government uh
prescribed lockdowns uh and ignored all
these other factors
that definitely as equally important as
we've seen from these
you know at least two out of the three
lockdowns it you know it was already on
the way down
before official rules came into play and
i think
you know we can argue about what
proportion of it but clearly
it can't have been due just to the
lockdown uh
other factors were already in play and
simon wood in your research you also
look at covet in sweden which of course
famously
never locked down in any of the of the
covered waves why do you think
sweden is is relevant to and
understanding the british situation
given how vastly different these two
countries are
well i think there's a couple of things
to say there i mean one is sweden
tends to get discarded as some sort of
outlier but really
it's the only place that did the
experiment and did something really
really different as a western european
country
now of course it is different in many
ways to the uk but on the other hand
it's also similar in some ways that the
densities in swedish cities are not that
different to the densities in uk cities
they do have large immigrant populations
um and and so on so i think
i think the thing about sweden is simply
that you know there are things there
that are very
very puzzling um if what you require is
complete
prescriptive lockdown in order to bring
the epidemic under control
it's it's puzzling that the catastrophe
widely predicted in sweden simply never
happened
that if you take the same models that
predicted you know really bad outcomes
in the uk
they predicted also extremely bad
outcomes for sweden and those things
didn't materialize
under the swedish policy so i think
there are some questions to answer there
now you can't simply say
you know what they did in sweden can
translate easily to the uk there are big
differences and and they will be part of
the difference
but i think you also can't ignore what
happened in sweden i'm tim spector what
do you think about the swedish example i
mean
obviously it's strange to compare any
two countries in this epidemic
right now but if it were going back to
your point
about how the potency of f of government
lockdown measures or non-first
npis non-pharmaceutical interventions if
they're overstated
then does for example sweden tell us
that the power of people's changing
behavior
um is the deciding factor it might have
been over there
absolutely and i've got swedish
colleagues you know telling me what was
happening on the ground and
we do have uh about 80 000 people from
sweden logging
also telling us what's going on on the
on the zoe app
so what we were seeing there is really
similar patterns of behavior
but not restricted by rules or
regulations
people uh would just react normally
uh to when they're you know they were
told the infection levels are high or
low and they would
act appropriately and that's probably
why
we saw no great difference
to to what was happening here or
actually is slightly less
but it is a less slightly less dense
country so i think there's more rural
elements to it but even in a place like
stockholm
uh i think it was the natural reactions
of individuals to space themselves
out and not have meetings you know given
warnings without
necessarily backed up by legal force and
fines etc
so people were just being sensible i i
think in a way that
hasn't really been talked about in this
country right so does that
make you think that the same system
might have worked here that people might
have used
common sense or folks vet as they call
it in
in sweden that the common sense and
people's behavior
might have had the same success in
driving the pandemic down
it as in sweden because as you say in
sweden the first wave and the second
wave
seemed to almost mirror the experience
of britain despite very very different
and policy responses i think that's true
uh in general i mean i think they're
going to be exceptions in some areas you
know we do have some
perhaps denser more deprived areas of
this country compared to sweden
where it might have been difficult to
control things
but i think it's all about giving people
the information
uh locally and making them feel they had
a
they were in control of it and i don't
think that really happened in this
country
i don't think the dissemination of what
the real risks were to people
at different times was there it was a
general you know
constant um fear that didn't really
allow flexibility in that system and i
think perhaps the swedes were more in
touch
with their health authorities in terms
in terms of getting that information out
to people um
plus you know that there's some evidence
that you know they
they have a higher level of higher
education as well so i also might have
been able to
more easily understand that information
all right now professor woods you
referred earlier to models that showed
that sweden would face
a catastrophe that didn't lock down
disproven models that i don't know if
you're referring to the imperial college
modeling but certainly
there was a paper from imperial that
came out in december that made a very
striking claim
that britain as we all know was about a
week 10 days later
when the rest of europe to lock down the
first time around
now imperial college's studies suggest
that that delay
led to extra 20 000 deaths avoidable
covert deaths in britain
because under his modelling the number
of infections rose
exponentially right up to lockdown on
23rd of march
and then it collapsed instantly that was
the model given lots of publicity
and now you've looked at that model and
you i mean
tell me what you make of it well so
there's a couple of things to say there
actually perhaps before mentioning the
model i should say that there's also the
really interesting
um results that come out from the react
2 study
on what happened around the first
lockdown and react 2 is a
it's a really proper statistical sample
where you take a representative sample
of people and and you're testing them
for antibodies to covet and then with
the people who tested positive they then
asked them about when their symptoms had
started and from that you can also do a
reconstruction of what was happening
including at the first lockdown which of
course you can't do with the ons server
so the reaction
study is a is an attempt to do what you
did to reconstruct what happened just
before lockdown one log down two
and what does the react 2 study show us
well so they've uh they've
uh reconstructed when the uh when people
were becoming infected
so the first day of infection over over
the course of
well basically up until now from from
right at the beginning on this basis and
that that study shows a very similar
pattern to what i got from the from the
death data
that once you allow for the time from
infection to first onset of symptoms
then what appears to be happening is
again that infections are dropping
before
lockdown now that of course is that that
contradicts what the imperial
the imperial uh study says right and so
tim spectre then finally and we've got
the react
to study the ons data we've got the zoe
study from your app
all of these is it the case that all of
these suggest
that coveted infections were falling
before lockdown
and if so does that mean that the whole
premise of the political conversation
that every day until lockdown was a day
of surging infections
might be based on a false premise
i think so when putting those black and
white terms yes i mean i i think
it's all a question of whether you think
the only message is the lockdown yes or
no
rather than giving people you know the
individual
warnings and risks to behave
appropriately
and i think that's what's been
underestimated and that's also you know
why the imperial
modeling got it got it so wrong is they
just totally didn't
factor in individual change as
bodies were appearing and ambulances all
over the place which is natural human
behavior they just assumed it was you
know
no change at all until that person died
or got covered and that's completely
ridiculous so
i think i think yes looking
retrospectively you know my view is that
uh the lockdown was not not the key
event
uh but it doesn't not to say that
lockdowns didn't
help uh somewhat in reducing the
uh the the in a way that
the peak of the scale or the problem or
it continuing longer but
definitely all the analysis point that
you know would pass that point when when
they were initiated
right so as we've seen you know lots of
data now are you aware of any data tim
specter but suggests the cases were
rising at the point of lockdown
um no good data that i'm aware of no
tim spector and simon wood thanks very
much for joining me on spectator tv
now a reminder about the spectator's new
app
it's out a few days ago it contains the
magazine our podcasts all of our blogs
we're offering it free of charge for a
three-month
trial period so if anybody wants to try
out that app it's on the
itunes store it's also on android go to
spectator dot co
dot uk forward slash tv offer
and see if you like the magazine and if
you like
the new app let us know if you don't the
email is the editor at spectator.co.uk
next onto kovid in india the situation
there is getting far
worse and although india is the world's
largest producer of the astrazeneca
vaccine its factory there is running
into big problems which raises an
interesting question
britain right now is sending ventilators
to india
but should we be sending vaccines as
well i'm joined by
adam ritchie from oxford university's
general institute
he helped advise on the production of
astrazeneca vaccines
here in britain and in india so adam
what do you think is going wrong in the
production factories
in india why are they encountering these
difficulties
which we seem not to have hit in britain
so i mean i
i can't speak for the serum institute
being a an employer of the university of
oxford and really speaking here in my
own capacity
but what we have seen uh is one
they are the biggest vaccine
manufacturer they are making the bulk
of the astrazeneca vaccine and vaccine
from the serum institute of india
has gone to dozens and dozens of
countries all over the world so
they've done a phenomenal job um you
know they've been pushing so hard to
scale up one of the
unreported or under reported tragedies
of the the
pandemic has been as as they were
expanding their facilities there was an
electrical accident and several young
men
uh working there on the electronics for
expanding their build and unfortunately
passed away
so they've done a phenomenal job what we
have
when it comes to vaccine manufacturing
is a very complicated process
that has very complex supply chains you
know dozens hundreds really of different
materials go into manufacturing these
these vaccine as i say it is very
complicated
and if you run out of any of those you
run into a problem of not being able to
make the vaccine there's it's no good
having 99
of the ingredients if you're missing
that one percent nothing will happen
the big global supply chains that feed
it we've seen people from the serum
institute of india
asking uh the us government to make sure
that they're able to get the materials
they need to make the astrazeneca
vaccine there at the serum institute
uh there was a little bit of a delay on
that but there's been announcements in
the last few days
from the white house that they're going
to look to how they can release those
items so that cereal means that you can
keep scaling up
and keep producing it at high levels but
across all the vaccine platforms we have
seen some bottlenecks around
different materials whether it's
consumables
media buffers or things like the
bioreactor
bags that the vaccines are growing in
there are some shortages and getting
those solved is one of the most
important things for ensuring ongoing
supply
are these global shortages that will
affect the way that we make our
astrozenica
vaccines here in britain or is it
something which is specific to india
so they can be there there is a broad
global shortages
issue uh obviously different governments
talk to each other in different ways so
and what sort of things can you give us
an example of what there's a shortage of
right now
well what there has been a shortage of
reporting a couple of places is some of
the bioreactor
growth bags that are used in different
vaccines
um you know one of the issues is supply
and
supply chains do tend to be global for
this because they're not
something that's easy to manufacture and
the reason for that is because
as i hope everyone would would
understand and
want to happen any material that goes
into manufacturing a vaccine anything
that touches it has to be fully
traceable has to meet these very high
regulatory standards you can't just use
any old bag to grow the cells in that
make the vaccine they have to be
all the plastic has to be traceable so
they're expensive they're more difficult
to make because all the materials have
to be
um fully traceable supply chain and so
it's quite you know the places that can
manufacture those much like the places
that make the vaccine itself they are
limited globally it's not every town
doesn't have its own factory making
these bags
so it does tend to be a few places
around the world making them
and so there are issues when one of them
runs out of the materials they need to
make the bags or whatever other item it
is they're making for the vaccine
and if there are shortages do we end up
with the situation that we've seen
with the vaccine purchase more generally
that perhaps that the company the
countries that or
that negotiated the best contracts they
make sure their supplies are coming in
because they've perhaps got it written
into their contract
that you absolutely have to give it to
us we've seen the eu they failed to get
that kind of stipulation it was the best
efforts only that's why the eu
is lagging here could it be the case
that the nature of the contracts
that india has signed with a vaccine
manufacturers have left it more exposed
than for example we might be
in this country with our relationship
with what you say is only
a handful of global suppliers for the
vaccine components
um i i don't know that's true i'd be i
mean
it's possible but i'd be surprised if
that's the explanation to me
uh the most likely explanations around
supply chains are primarily
that there's not enough for what
everyone wants so so we have an issue i
think the most likely cause for one
country getting it over
another is whether they have the supply
chain internally
you know so if your country's making the
bioreactor bags and you put a
export block on them it's quite easy to
keep them in the country
and what's the situation in brisbane can
they ask do we import our bioreactor
bags
uh we probably import most of them and
we're not facing shortages though i
can't quite work out
why we aren't affected by the same thing
as india is so
so if you look at the serum institute of
india they're producing phenomena
you know i mean the manufacturers here
are producing fantastic amounts but the
serum institute of india is on another
scale they
they have a much bigger facility many
more bioreactors running so they
uh require more components more often
because they produce more
right now isn't there a moral a
difficult moral question coming up right
now we in this country are offering
vaccines to people who
have already had the virus therefore the
extra protection they're likely to get
from a vaccine
is is minimal if it exists at all
whereas so the vaccine which could be
marginal for one of the many people in
britain who've had covet
could be a matter of life and death for
a pensioner in
india and so does this not raise ethical
questions about
our obligation to india and whether we
might be able to
perhaps say it in this country look if
you've had the virus you don't need to
come forward for the vaccine and we can
see we can send a little more supplies
to the indian people who are literally
dying for the lack of vaccines
and look i think obviously there isn't
an ethical question there there's a big
difference between
you know what is legally allowed and
what what
contracts say you can and can't do you
know if the uk has doses they
are the uk's doses the ethical question
then of what
happens to those doses and how they're
most effectively used is a big one and
of course
uh the world health organization the
kovacs facility
um that they're a big part of with
unicef and gates and various others
you know one of their big goals is to
try and deal with that to try and
almost get a pool of vaccines that can
be distributed based on need rather than
ability to pay now
there is that ethical question there i'd
love to say that i think
humans are very good at uh being
rational about these things and going
yes we
will share our resources and those
things but i haven't seen it happen with
many other things
um there's some of it happening here but
not as much as we'd like so
there is an imperative to go if we've
had enough vaccines if our high risk
groups have vaccinated then maybe yes
vaccine doses should be going to india
or
you know three months from now what's
happening in india may be happening
somewhere else in the world sort of
thing so preparing for that
for those of us here at oxford who are
involved in the
setting up the manufacturing process and
working with astrazeneca and others on
that
this was always a big problem we saw
coming the
best way we thought to deal with that
was this sort of distributed
manufacturing that's why
you know there's over a dozen countries
now or about a dozen countries that are
manufacturing the
the astrozenica vaccine that way you
have different
supply chains in different places so if
one you know if one didn't work that can
impact that area a bit more but what it
does
hopefully mean is that you know all the
doses don't just go to the uk
the eu and the us and other other
wealthy countries that can just afford
to pay the manufacturer the most
right so you're saying that right at the
start of this then you and your team
envisaged
the scenario hardly hard to envisage
where we would vaccinate all of our
at-risk
groups and and then there'd be questions
as to whether there'd be other poorer
countries who would need it
to save lives whereas we might be
pursuing it too for slightly different
reasons put it that way
so so what i'd say is we thought at the
start you know what the most important
thing in our driver is always
getting vaccine into people's arms
that's you know how many
lives can you say how can you open up
society again by getting vaccines to
people
and one of the things we did see was the
potential that
that countries where vaccines are being
manufactured
would hold on to those vaccines use them
in very low risk groups or even hold on
to them just in case they're needed
rather than being fairly distributed you
know
what we've done hasn't made it perfectly
fairly distributed but it's worth noting
that the astrazeneca vaccine is forming
the backbone and most of the doses that
have gone out through kovacs
have been uh that vaccine and the bulk
of them produced at
serum institute and a few other sites
around the world
right but are we not close to that
scenario now i mean
um please correct me if i've got this
wrong but somebody who has had
covid is as pretty much a young person
who's had covet is as low risk as you
can probably
get right now and yet these people are
being offered vaccines
in britain where that vaccine could save
a life of an indian pensioner
yeah and that's that's that where that
moral question sits the
the question is how happy are
the electors or the the people of the uk
for for that to happen and and you'll
you'll hear different views on that and
different ethical standpoints that
some people feel we need to protect
people here the most since we have the
vaccines
others would like to see them shared
more equally globally
and it depends on where you where you
sort of see the ethics of that situation
um there are of course all sorts of
points here around
why two doses what's the difference
between a vaccine dose and natural
infection
it may very well be that having a
vaccine offers longer protection than
the natural infection and it may very
well be that having two doses of the
vaccine
offers prolonged protection over
multiple years which
which will be quite important for
instance it would not be overly useful
or would be
not a great thing if the first doses of
the vaccine gave us good immunity for
for a period but then if we didn't take
the second dose
that immunity waned off so that suddenly
we needed another two doses a year from
now or something like that
these are things that the data is
starting to tell us about how long is
the immunity how long lasting
what's it made up of antibodies t cells
different parts of the immune system
so there are still some questions there
to answer but broadly if you're asking
me personally
do i think we should be sending some
vaccines over overseas to places where
they'd have more impact
my view on that would be yes the general
institute primarily works on diseases
um that that of the developing world of
low and middle income countries
diseases like malaria and uh ebola and
things like that
rabies uh and so you know we're always
looking
to to roll out vaccines that can save
the most lives
no matter where those lives are is it
the case that britain originally
and just envisaged getting vaccines to
cover the at-risk population i seem to
remember kate bingham
talking in those terms right at the
start of the program
i i don't think or you know you'd you'd
have to ask kate and
the ministers about exactly what their
thinking was
the plan at our end was always just
because once you're making it you can
keep making the plan at our end was just
to make as much vaccine as we can
in as diverse as a bunch of geographical
locations as we could
and whether those doses were going to be
for the uk
or for somewhere else that wasn't our
primary driver our primary driver was
what
is going to let us have the most doses
of vaccine and then
hope that they end up with the right
people in the right time frame
adam thanks very much for joining us on
spectator tv
now on to cyber warfare british troops
are going to be joining their ukrainian
counterparts in the next few weeks
to prepare for operations gaming what
they would do if
russia escalated the aggression over
there
now vladimir putin said last week that
any response by russia
would be asymmetrical in other words he
might have other tricks up his sleeve
now
might those tricks include cyber warfare
we've known for some time
that russia has quite sophisticated
hacking capabilities as does china
as does north korea so what might we be
experiencing them
next time something hits off in the
battlefield far away
professor noel sharkey who's at the
university of sheffield will be known to
many of you as a judge
on robot wars he's written in the
features saying we should be very
concerned indeed about
the capabilities of our potential
adversary he joins me now
along with sir richard dearlove who used
to be head of mi6
so professor sharkey let's start with
you we've known
about cyber warfare for a very long time
why should we be any more concerned now
than we were i don't know 10
15 years ago well quite a lot has
happened in fact i mean we know about
for instance
ransomware attacks on our hospitals on
our schools
those are all hacks but also it's
increasing dramatically there's a lot of
cyber espionage
into our industry for instance massively
people repair repelling hits all the
time and
we really need to uh do something more
than we are
uh we need to educate the public more
about password security for instance
uh because we have a we're pretty
insecure i would say generally
in the civilian world right
but is that strategic i mean i mean for
example if things were to heat up in
ukraine is there any serious risk
that putin or forces sympathetic to
putin might
switch the lights off in aberdeen or
something like that
they could do they've demonstrated that
kind of capability
uh we now have a i mean according to the
new defense review
we're developing uh cyber warriors or or
cyber force but
that's not going to protect civilians so
much we don't have
one of the problems i have is we don't
really have
contingency plans and the ransomware
attacks have demonstrated this really
clearly to me where ambulances are
knocked out
and hospital records and we can't access
patients
and it's possible as well because we use
so many
internet of things devices and by that i
mean the likes of alexa
or even internet toothbrushes or you
know
trivial things really our heating
systems for instance use these
nest controllers that are controlled by
the internet
those are all very hackable and what you
can do is once you can get in there
because people don't change the
the password and also passwords are
being sold
stolen and so large scale on the dark
dark web and things like joker bazaar so
we have all these
insecure devices and once you get into
one of these devices
you can use that recruit many more
and then you have this idea of a ddos
attack
denial distributed denial of services
attack
that brought netflix the guardian
twitter down last year
um and so how can we stop this
and having a cyber force in charge of
our security is insufficient
what we really need is a national
program of education
about how our you know my toothbrush
i don't have an internet toothbrush
because i think it's ridiculous
but my internet toothbrush if i had one
could cause
real problems for security in this
country generally
now sir richard i wouldn't ask if you've
got an internet say toothbrush but
you were not a great fan of huawei's
being involved in
in british infrastructure but what i
can't work out
then and now is surely mi6 gchq
gchq the british security services are
once
a one step ahead of russia of china
surely our defenses are equal to any
attack
which our far smaller more poorer
adversaries might have up their sleeve
well i'm not sure that that's true i
mean the problem
that we have in the uk or any
advanced liberal democracy
is uh as uh
professor shaki's already emphasized
is that we don't have um you know
sufficiently
sufficient ability to control
the civilian infrastructure um okay some
critical infrastructure is well
protected but
there are so many gaps and
vulnerabilities in a free society
and i mean what you have to bear in mind
is if you take
the chinese the chinese have built
their own systems in a way which is
quite different
from how we you know conceive our own
infrastructure
and um the fusion between civilian
military and academic life in china is
now very sophisticated so a company
like huawei has massive degree of
contact with the chinese military
and the chinese military is closely
integrated
into all chinese major universities
so they have learned very fast and
they've built themselves
a defensive and offensive cyber
capability
um and they've learned from their
mistakes very very quickly
that there's a concept in sigit
or collection which is called shaping
the environment
i.e building architecture which is
favorable
to your strategic objectives
for us to do that in the west is is is
possible but very complex and very
difficult
but for the chinese to do that uh
is they have developed a very
sophisticated
infrastructure so if you take huawei and
zte the
main telecommunications companies
um we are
if we use their equipment we become
vulnerable to the sophistication of
their architecture
i think that's the best way that i can
explain it
and i mean i i was shocked by
the naivety of the government in their
attitude
towards huawei becoming involved in our
5g systems or or being so deeply
embedded
in them and um i i'm absolutely
delighted that the decision eventually
has been
taken to exclude them um
you know we we will over time i mean
it's not a simple
issue we can't just close the door but
we will reduce
our vulnerabilities undoubtedly
so richard when you were learning your
spycraft it was relatively
straightforward you knew
who the bad guys were you knew if they
were doing something bad and where
but now when you try to trace the origin
of cyber attacks i remember a few years
ago
one of them which was regarded as north
korean cyber attack was traced to an
internet cafe
in brighton now almost certainly it
wasn't organized from there but it's
very easy
to disguise your origins very difficult
to retaliate
if you can't be completely sure where
the attack came from in the first place
so
surely we the the asymmetricality that
putin refers to
is not simply the fact that he might
have capabilities that we lack
but he would be able to use methods of
concealing that would make it very
difficult for us
to work out who we even direct our
return of fire to
well i think attribution is a
significant problem
but i mean
when this problem you know
let's say over time accumulated a
significant profile
i think some of the early cyber attacks
the trade craft behind them was
reasonably poor an attribution was more
straightforward and
easier but the chinese as it were
learned a lot
let's say from snowden's revelations
about
what um you know the west's capability
was and in fact they've much
upped their game they're much more
sophisticated now
and there are ways that you can as it
were
divert your attack to other people's
servers and obviously
the internet cafe in brighton is a
typical example
there's no way the attack came from
there and
and you know you remember that we have
this capability ourselves
uh and you know it isn't an important
way of collecting intelligence on
strategic targets
but when you look at the way
that the chinese have up their games
you have to up your defensive
sophistication to keep abreast of the
problem
and i mean in a way it is a type of arms
race
uh and i think one of the problems is
that there is very little
international agreement at the moment to
as it were prevent this constant
escalation
i mean obama did a deal with xi ping
briefly which was signed i think in
seattle during that famous visit
but you know whether the chinese have
respected that it's an
open question whether the americans have
respected it is an open question and
at the moment you know we're getting
we're upping the game we're upping the
sophistication
and i i think one of the problems that
we've got in the west that we don't
have the the sort of authoritarian
control of resources to match
the massive effort that the chinese are
putting into this i mean the third
people the third and fourth people's
liberation
armies are largely devoted
entirely to this cipher issue and their
china's cipher capability but there's
one important thing to remember about
this
is you know why do the chinese want to
shape uh
you know their environment their
electronic environment
it's actually not us they're worrying
about it's their own population
so the primary objective of
china's type of uh cyber capability
it is it is is control within their own
country
and their offensive capability is an
extension
of that control all right so professor
sharkey that's the problem isn't it
they're simply
asymmetricality of rules of engagement
and they simply will do things which we
wouldn't do for moral ethical or legal
reasons
so no matter how good our technology our
technology
might be we'd never probably be able to
um
deploy it or defend it simply because
they're using piracy rules
and we're not pirates um well
i wouldn't like to take the moral high
ground too much here
to be honest and i think sir richard
could testify to that
uh though i doubt he will it's it's not
a matter of that
and the problem with attribution that
you bring up is so important
because there's no reason why taiwan for
instance couldn't make it look
as if it was a china chinese attack now
i was at a conference with very senior
people from the u.s military
including their cyber division and the
the
idea there was that maybe we don't need
absolute proof
maybe we can just use suspicion of
particular circumstances
and then that would unleash a kinetic
attack now the worry is that when russia
are threatening and talking about
asymmetry
supposing china was now to attack us if
we did something
in ukraine and china decided to attack
us
under the cloak of russia we would think
it was russia
and that is this it's just getting out
of hand
and one of the big problems is as we've
as sir richard just said was
a complete lack of international
regulation
i mean anthony gutierrez at the un two
years ago
brought this up and said we really
desperately urgently need new regulation
but nobody's taking it up and i would
like britain to step up really
and push on this because we're not that
strong and we need to be pushing on it
and you know the international committee
of the red cross
who look after the geneva conventions
etc
say that there are laws that you you
know the
the laws of war ihl and ihl dictates
that you cannot attack
civilians you must discriminate in an
armed conflict now ihl only applies to
armed conflict
what if it's not an armed conflict we
don't have international regulations for
that
um whether or not you think people will
obey them that's not the matter
we have speed limit on our road and most
people break it
but it's a bit of elastic that kind of
holds us back from going too far
okay and so richard one final question
to you we've seen recently that um
that the mi5 is being involved in a leak
inquiry apparently
what do you think of this the
intelligence agencies being brought back
to find out
which special advisor briefed what's to
the press this typically hasn't been the
job
of our intelligence agencies
um well i mean leak inquiries
have a sort of very varied history in
the uk
um and uh i mean in a way it's quite
sensible perhaps to use the resources of
mi5 if it's politically important and
you know one needs to pin something down
um
well i'm not quite sure what the drift
of your question is
well i'm just wondering in your day i
bet you'd be quite surprised if you
if you pick somebody picked up the phone
from number 10 saying look uh we reckon
somebody briefed it to the press would
you guys in mi6 please kindly tell us
who did it i mean
you wouldn't have well mi6 doesn't
definitely doesn't do that sort of thing
i mean you know we are an offensive
uh in intelligence agency
but i i mean in the past retired
senior mi6 officers has been used for
leak inquiries
and i i don't see anything particularly
surprising about that
i mean they're usually driven out of the
cabinet office
leak inquiries and um i think even when
the resources of mi6 haven't been
publicly
uh announced as being used they're
possibly using a couple of mi5 officers
to help
who are you know professional
investigators therefore know what
they're doing but there's one important
point that we've left out of this
discussion
about attribution and of course
it's the important still of human source
intelligence
because if you want to be clear about
what the chinese are doing and you can't
work it out
through uh you know technical
attribution
if you have a source buried in the right
place
you know in the right bit of the
people's liberation army you can get
most of these questions
answered because that's one of the
reasons why snowden was so
damaging because he did as a human
the source betrayed both the russians
and to the chinese you know
massive areas of american and actually
british capability
in the areas of siege we are to an
extent fortunate in the uk
because of our sophistication and and
the the the depths of expertise that
rest at gchq
but it it's a fantastic asset
which is being diminished in value for
the reasons that
we've explained a little bit in this uh
discussion
right so richard you're basically saying
we need to get um we need to
we can get somebody on the inside in the
people's liberation army or in north
korea and they can just basically tell
us
who did what one of the ways of
understanding what the
you know capability is being aimed at us
it's a combination
of you know your technical knowledge and
your human
coverage if you can put the two together
you get a reasonably complete picture
richard noel thank you very much indeed
for joining me
now that's it for this week on spectator
tv i'd like again to thank our sponsor
charles stanley one of the oldest firms
on the london stock exchange and one of
britain's leading wealth management
companies
now if we're you'd like to give some
feedback on spectator tv we're always
very pleased to receive it you can also
like or subscribe
the channel if you want to hear from us
again which i would hope
you do thanks for watching and thanks
very much to max jeffrey our producer
[Music]
you